لديها وسائل للضغط اذن لكنها تحاول
الاستفاده تريد واشنطن ضمانه وجود عسكريا
ومستقرا لها في سوريا ورغم تخليصي عدد
القوات الى 900 عسكري لكن هناك ضغط
الاعلام الامريكيه تساءل عن مدى جدوى
الوجود في سوريا وسيله الولايات المتحده
في الضمان وجودها هو اقامه مشروع جديد في
مناطق شمال شرق سوريا لكن ذلك سيفقد قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه المتحالفه معه جزءا من
نفوذها فيها واشنطن تعتزم بناء تحالف جديد
بين الجناح السياسي لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه واطراف اخرى من المعارضه بما
يشمل زياده نسبه المكون العربي في
المؤسسات السياسيه والعسكريه شمال شرقي
سوريا وفي هذا الاطار تطالب واشنطن قصد
بفك ارتباطها نهائيا بحزب العمال
الكردستاني قصد اكدت اخيرا ان لا علاقه
لها بالحزب والمصنف كارها
لكن رغم كل ذلك تمتلك قصد ورقه حاسمه
ومنطقيه امام جميع الاطراف الخصوم
والشركاء ولوحت بها اي عمليه عسكريه تركيه
ستحول دون استمرارنا في استهداف عناصر
داعش وحتى قدرتنا على حراسه معسكرات
اعتقالهم
اذن تقليص او انهاء للنفوذ الكردي شمال
شرق سوريا يفيد دوله اخرى الوسيط روسيا
موسكو ستتخلص من حليف واشنطن في سوريا
وايضا ستنجح في زياده رقعه الاراضي
الواقعه تحت سياده النظام السوري حليفها
لكن هناك لاعب محوري في الازمه السوريه لم
تشمله التغيرات الجيوسيه الجديده ايران
عالميا لم تخفي طهران انزعاجها من التقارب
السوري التركي دون ضوء اخضر منها وانزعاج
انعكس في قرار الحد من تزويد دمشق بالوقود
باسعار مخفضه موقفه طهران يزداد وضوحا مع
تحركاتها الدبلوماسيه زيارتان مفاجئتان
لدمشق وانقره قام بهما وزير الخارجيه
الايرانيه حسين امير عبداللهيان في الرابع
عشر والسابع عشر من يناير الماضي على
التوالي التي اعاقبتها تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه النظام السوري من طهران بان
التقارب مع انقره يجب ان على اسس انهاء ما
قال انه احتلال ومكافحه ارهاب
المصالح هي اساس والتقارب هكذا يفهم مساره
التطبيع بين تركيا والنظام السوري انقره
التي تسارع الخطى على هذا الطريق تهدف الى
اعاده ثلاثه ملايين الف لاجئ سوري على
اراضيها الى بلادهم ايضا استئناف العلاقات
التجاريه وفتح المعابر المغلقه بين
البلدين منذ اكثر من عقد لكن الهدف
الاساسي هو القضاء على الحلم الكردي
المتشكل في الشمال الشرقي تحت السلطه
العسكريه لقوات قصد هدف تتناغم فيه موسكو
مع انقره قد يعيد النظام الى الشمال
الشرقي الغني بالنفط والموارد المائيه
والزراعيه لكن هناك سد امريكي الطريق
معقده والمفاوضات ليست سهله فما يفرق
الخصمين اكثر مما يجمعهما مثالا الاسد
استخدم الكيماوي في دوما انقره تدين وترفض
بينما دمشق تنفي صراع المواقف واختلافاتها
قد يطيح بالفرص التي اتاحها اللقاء الاخير
في موسكو بين الطرفين